good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday hope everyone
had an amazing weekend i am thrilled
overjoyed and humbled to be sitting here
with icon
jewel author yeah former slash current
real housewives of new york hello liam
mcsweeney thank you so much for being
here finally so happy to be here
overjoyed doesn't even begin to express
it
thank you it doesn't thank you well your
timing couldn't be better because we
spent much of last week talking about
real housewives of new york right and
the drama and the two shows and i'm
curious if you know currently
what that means for you
i don't think any of us know what that
means for us
right
yeah well because you
i i could see you being eligible
technically for both shows right that's
true the new i am i am eligible for both
right because you're like where do you
think i'm going to end up where would
you want to see me i'm curious i think i
would want to see you on the on
the the new show the legacy yeah because
it's always felt like two different
groups like since you're you're so much
younger and you're so really so
different than the other women yeah and
i do think that like if the show was
built around you your friends people
your age people you know socially i do
think it would just be like a fresher
dynamic got you that's just my all no no
i i like your opinion um
i also i'm like oh my god though if like
dorinda is coming back and if it's then
it's like i know you backed out because
i felt i had so much fun on season 12 of
them yeah i personally feel like
dorinda
is not the vibe
and i do think like i i really believe
that you would be like the star of the
new reboot i really think that do you
have a preference
i i don't honestly i don't like i i
found out the news obviously i was
surprised but
i'm just kind of like i'll see what
happens right i'm very like i don't i
you know
it's just not in my control so i'll just
see what happens do you love being a
real housewife
it has so many perks and it has also
some downsides like everything that's
true but overall
definitely it's been a positive thing
for sure yeah well you now wrote a book
and obviously there's a huge platform
for you to promote your book exactly
it's called chaos theory yes tell us a
little bit about it uh chaos theory
finding meaning in the madness one bad
decision at a time it's it's a memoir
like i'm not gonna say it's not
prescriptive it's maybe there's some
part prescriptive in there
but it really
chronicles like my from teenage
delinquency to like now basically and i
touch on a lot of subjects have you been
told that you're too young to write a
memoir
no oh
i feel like that's something people say
really yeah i mean i'm almost 40. no but
you look like what 11. oh okay you look
great oh yeah okay okay
i'm just bettering you up because
honestly i'm so excited that you're here
your timing couldn't be better coming
off the heels of the real housewives
drama and also
your recent conversion to judaism which
i'm just obsessed with obviously because
i'm a very proud jew and you know being
a jew is not easy like i should just
tell you like we are extremely disliked
by a lot of people i'm finding that out
and i'm curious like who the [ __ ] would
make that decision to like
willingly join a group of people with so
much trauma i know i you know i'm
realizing that you guys i don't i didn't
understand how much you guys were
disliked until i started telling people
i was converting oh really not that i
hadn't been aware of anti-semitism and
things like that obviously like um but
telling people like sometimes i get a
why
right and i'm like
why not right would you what if i said i
was like going to be born again
christian right buddhist or i don't
think i'd get those kinds of like
same responses right exactly and of
course like when i first said i was
converting orthodox people like um which
i didn't i converted conservatives at a
conservative shul but also the
the um
confusion like ortho people think
orthodox is like scary and meanwhile my
orthodox rabbi is like the chillest
coolest yeah i'm still friends with no
people
all backwards and they just are not
informed and you know who i blame
netflix
oh my god i know i just think like every
time they highlight a jewish community
it's like the worst outskirt i know part
of it and people who've never met you in
their life that's all they see they're
like oh it's crazy women are surprised
exactly
i can't i'm so glad you're joining the
tribe i just feel like we're really
lacking in like the cool celebrity like
proud jew department like i'm proud i'm
obsessed with celebrities and i'm
constantly finding out celebrities are
jewish because they never talk about it
you know so lame and so embarrassing for
them so weird why would you not so it's
been like less than a week since you've
been like full
yes i can i had my mikvah on wednesday
of last week i believe did you enjoy the
mikvah experience i loved it which one
did you go to uh upper west side okay
i've been to the one on the upper east
side it's literally like a stunning spa
experience yeah this one was very nice
for those who don't know mikveh is in
sex in the city when charlotte goes into
the the richard
so you do it to convert you also do it
um before you get married which is when
i did it and it was like a stunning very
like it's not what i expected but you
could still keep doing it
i was planning on keeping like doing
nida which is like i'm not gonna get
into it but it's like a monthly thing
for your period like when you are
married um but i just like never found
the time and i'm like upset with myself
that i never like continued on it's just
so like the bath was so warm
and it's just i was like is this real it
was surreal because i've been thinking
about this moment for so long yes i've
been working towards it for two years
but it's actually been a lifetime yeah
and it's been since my early 20s that
i've played with the idea of converting
to judaism so it was just finally like
doing something for myself and like
actually
taking steps to create a life i want for
myself and it was you know it's pretty
big deal no it was it's so cool are you
gonna raise your daughter jewish so
she's catholic she goes to catholic
school
but yeah exactly but um i'm getting her
dna done because i have a feeling her
her paternal great grandmother
was a french jew that was hiding like
the jewish right but i don't know until
i get her dna tested and i literally
just i'm sending it out today oh that's
so interesting yeah i did mine i'm just
irish and italian that's it i did mine
i'm 99.9 ashkenazi jewish and my husband
was 100.
like crazy that is crazy like we are so
boring
um okay i'm so excited that you're here
to join we're going to talk all things
lots of drama obviously everyone is
talking about what went down in the
oscars last night and honestly the
oscars were like some of the most boring
pieces of [ __ ] i've ever watched until
that moment obviously i was gonna turn
it off too but something in my brain was
like let's just watch it we have to do
the show tomorrow and the world is
honestly never gonna be the same after
what happened like everyone's talking
about the will smith chris rock drama
we're obviously going to talk about it
and just other news that went down over
the weekend so without further ado i
think it's time that we dive into the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
below deck good day yachties your
favorite reality franchise is charting a
course for australia in peacock's new
original series below deck down under on
a super yacht near the great barrier
reef it's not just the waves that rock
the boat each charter of outrageous
guests presents new challenges for the
audi hotties but you can count on them
to work hard and play harder besides
there may be sharks in the water but
this crew has a bite of its own fan
favorite aisha from below deck med is
back as chiefs too while the hunky
newcomer jason has everyone saying aye
aye captain and adding in yacht-sized
egos and dueling deckhands you bet
there's drama on the horizon so if
you're looking for the ultimate escape
pull up that anchor and come aboard
below deck downunda is streaming with
new episodes every thursday only on
peacock
today's episode is also brought to you
by fastgrowingtrees.com spring and
summer are the season for finally
getting outdoors for entertaining pool
parties and barbecues but if your yard
looks like a plant cemetery then you're
not going to enjoy it as much so get
your place looking like a resort with
fast growing trees when it comes to
caring for your plants know how matters
and that's why frescoing
frescoingtree.com
expert curate thousands of plant
varieties that will thrive in your
specific climate location and needs
there's no waiting in lines and no messy
cars from hauling plants all over town
because you order online or over the
phone and your plants are shipped to
your door in one to two days plus their
growing and care advice is available 24
7.
even if you've never had a green thumb
they'll make you feel like you do one
million home gardeners have already seen
that fastgrowingtrees.com
can do for them so go to
fastgrowingtrees.com
toast right now you'll get 15 off your
entire order that's 15 off at
fastgrowingtrees.com
toast
fastgrowingtrees.com toast i'm also
excited lee is here because today's
monday and that's where we do our
unburden ourselves segment where people
write in
the embarrassing things that happen to
them this weekend and just you know
sharing is caring and i think
a lot of the things we hold inside
once we let them go and just say them
speak them it makes us feel so much
better and that's what we try to do here
at the morning toast you know what they
say you're you're only as sick as your
secrets so [ __ ] true
um okay so let's just obviously talk
about the first story of the day which
is the will smith of it all
so if you were watching the oscars like
this is how it went down you were
watching and you were bored and you were
like should i turn this off no let's
keep watching and then chris rock came
out and you're like oh my god finally
someone funny love love love love yeah
so he's talking he makes a joke about um
jada pinkett smith she is bald
and he said he's looking forward to the
gi jane two movie because gi jana has a
shaved head they cut to will and jada
will is laughing and jada is rolling her
eyes like obviously annoyed and then
seemingly out of nowhere will smith is
on stage
and he
slaps chris rock so i was confused was
it was a slap or a punch in the pictures
being circulated his hand is flat but it
looked like a punch right and chris rock
was like taken aback physically yes but
you know what also will smith looks much
bigger than chris rock and chris rock
could [ __ ] handle it like he did not
he just you know kind of he kind of like
100
and i think the viewers at home were
like oh my god the oscars and they're
moronic like fake comedy i thought it
was a hundred percent staged because
really you're right chris rock like
didn't did not move it was yeah no he
didn't really
my tv went silent for 15 minutes and i
was like what the [ __ ] and i'm like
rewinding i thought i was broken
and then they cut to will smith and the
volume is off but you can hear him
saying keep my wife's name out your
[ __ ] mouth yeah
and then the volume finally comes back
and chris rock is like oh my god i just
got bit slapped by
will smith on tv and he continued on
with his monologue but he was like
visibly um
shaken
chris rock is not one to mince words and
he was like fumbling over the
teleprompter obviously but at that point
i think a lot of us didn't know that it
was real and we were all just
collectively like
what the [ __ ]
and then i guess the telecast here in
america was muted for about 10 or 15
seconds but they were airing it in japan
and australia and then people started to
share on social media it wasn't muted in
those countries and the real story came
out which was it was 100 real he got up
and slapped him and then walked off
stage and screamed at the top of his
lungs twice keep my wife's name out of
your [ __ ] mouth
so i don't want i haven't watched the
oscars in years i haven't really walked
i can't deal with the celebrities giving
theirs
it's like extra woke like annoying
virtuous like hypocritical [ __ ] like i
just can't deal with it i like seeing
the outfits of course but they're just
not fun anymore so i just don't watch it
but like i went to a comedy show and
said last night so but i did see the
clip of course of course and i mean
chris rock's a comedian yeah he is there
to make jokes and make fun of people
like
get a [ __ ] life will smith
i don't know i'm not into it at all
obviously the backlash for those who
don't know is uh if it wasn't listen if
it wasn't a comedian and someone just
randomly said that then i get it but in
this context that was like a total
oversensitive
[ __ ] move and you know what i don't
even think like debating back and forth
about whether the joke was appropriate
or not is worth it because once you put
hands on someone like you're wrong
you're 100 wrong you're done you're done
he's a comedian he's a comedian and you
know what's so funny is that like will
smith like actually did laugh at the
joke like and then he saw jaden was like
oh [ __ ] so i guess the only redeeming
quality in my opinion is that we love a
man who stands up for his wife of course
but i'm sorry like being violent is
never the answer doing it on tv this is
like a family friendly telecast there
was kids in the audience like it's so
not appropriate it's so not cool and
like it's making me like hate will smith
yeah if i was listen if i was at a bar
with my man and someone said something
to me and he punched him i'd be like i'm
sucking your dick all night tonight
you know what i mean like we're yeah
that's happening but this was just this
was immature yeah it seemed just like a
very fragile man that like couldn't
handle himself well that's what it
seemed like and then and i love chris
rock i know and he's a legend he didn't
deserve that and he was poking fun at
everyone and you know she's been open
about her she has alopecia and so
that's why she has a shaved head and yes
of course if you want to get into the
nitty-gritty maybe it wasn't sensitive
i'm
almost 100 sure he didn't know she had
alopecia i didn't even know i didn't
know either and i do this for a living
so it's
if there was you know uh
an issue with the joke it's a
conversation is the perfect place for
that off-camera it was not the place and
then i found myself like rooting for
will smith because i'm like i need to
hear from this man and the only way i'm
going to hear from him is if he wins and
he did win oh my god and he made a
speech yeah i've watched part of that
too he was extremely emotional and i
just really felt like we were watching
like the man in the midst of a breakdown
like yeah it looked like that you know
what you got to go to keith mcnally's
instagram
and see his breakdown of will smith's
speech
now he's like the best instrument he's
you know what i'm talking about i do not
he owns balthazar and
okay yes but his instagram is wild oh my
god gotta follow it's you have to follow
him you're gonna love it okay i love it
and what did he say he said that it was
the most self-indulgent self-important
speech he's like you know cries on cue
anyway so you can't trust him i mean he
was not he didn't mince his words so the
speech was weird because he obviously
like he was circling the drain like
talking about how richard williams who
he plays in the movie king richard venus
and serena's sister and then they cut to
venus and serena and venus's nipple was
hanging out like it was so hard to see
that it was chaos um he said you know
richard williams was a fierce defender
of his family
she was like he never really addressed
he apologized he apologized to everyone
except for chris rock he apologized to
the academy he apologized to um everyone
in the room
and it was just so messy i'm honestly i
wasn't able to follow the speech at all
i wasn't sure like what the overall
message was
um i just feel like will smith like
might be going through it right now
because he was acting like a fool yeah
he's the whole night not an excuse but
he's going through it 100 yeah to have
that much rage and anger in you like to
get up and
punch someone over a joke that i mean
that's what they're there to do right
you know unsafe no and i do have to say
i thought the three hosts regina wanda
and amy schumer were hilarious isn't it
crazy how
like think about will smith and jade
definitely like how much money they have
like will smith has everything and he's
still
like angry yeah like or as ken get that
angry right
and you know what i was thinking um
oh [ __ ] what was i gonna say
that
oh oh i imagine that the discourse we
would all be having around this
conversation would be enormously
different if it was a girl who got up
there and slapped someone like she would
be psychotic she would have been thrown
out like oh yeah you know and it's just
like yes she would have been on his
right a mad woman oh yeah completely so
the whole and i don't know
everyone then giving him a standing
ovation and it wasn't like it was
nothing the police were there and they
asked chris rock if he wanted to press
charges and he said no of course p diddy
has at the after party he was like doing
interviews he said that the two of them
have settled it
um
but it's just like it's like the
craziest thing it is pretty crazy and
then um
their son jayden took to twitter and was
and just tweeted that's how you do it
but unclear if he was referring to his
dad's speech or his dad's
slap unclear it was the slap heard
around the world it was so crazy he's
talking about this slap i think so too
yeah um and then the academy had to
release a statement a lot of people are
saying he might have his oscar taken
away they say they don't they do not
condone violence they release something
on twitter just being like we're here to
celebrate all the nominees et cetera et
cetera and we don't need non-violence i
don't think they should take his oscar
away but i also think it's just like
it doesn't make him look good no it
doesn't and like i'm curious if this is
like gonna be a thing for him like he's
gonna have to take a year off you know
like release a documentary or something
right like how you know every time you
go through a scandal it's like silence
and documentary yeah um i don't know i
feel like there's a lot of cannibals
what's that cannibal guy also that's
exactly kevin harted you know right and
then the guy who said he was like wanted
to eat women no oh yeah yeah army hammer
yeah it's always silence than
documentary he's been gone he's working
on himself but he's also in a move in an
upcoming movie so it's like no one's
actually came
like that you know yeah that's what's
been a year and now he's back and he
doesn't want to eat women anymore
[Laughter]
um so this was just like the craziest
thing i like really can't get over it i
honestly couldn't sleep like not to be
dramatic i was just like what the [ __ ]
just happened like
nothing interesting really ever happens
at the oscars i feel like this is
just as crazy maybe crazier than like
the whole la la land moonlight thing oh
my god i didn't watch that yeah that was
and in real time we were all like what
the [ __ ] that was and like no one was
able to talk about anything else for
like years yeah so honestly as a pop
culture junkie i was just like not gonna
lie living for every moment and the
oscars in my opinion have never been
more relevant did you see a lot of the
movies
i haven't seen any of those movies i
haven't even heard of them i'm like
where am i same but i started googling
some of them and i want to see coda that
sounds cool that's the what i took away
is the movie that i have to see i have
to see that too i did see tammy faye
which i need to watch that i need to
watch i'm obsessed with her it was
unreal like it was a she was amazing the
movie was good but she was incredible
which takes us to the next story which
is the list of winners in the main
categories jessica chastain did win and
she beat out like a sickening group
jessica chastain playing tammy
yeah oh my god
and also they tammy faye won for like
hair and makeup and costume because you
will not recognize just
all the like pictures and stuff right i
had no idea it was jessica chastain no
because she's like a goddess and she did
not look anything like herself she's a
ginger goddess she's a ginger goddess
she's jackie's like your sister yes
so the big categories will smith
obviously won for best actor best
actress was jessica chastain best
original song where beyonce was
nominated and billy eilish billy eilish
won and her and her brother were like
super cute like accepting the award how
nice to be able to go you're really
close with your sister like i was
thinking that when i was watching the
red carpet with like chloe and hallie
like they get to go everywhere together
like how nice is that that's fun like
you just have like a friend everywhere
you go who's like just as famous as you
like you get invited to all the cool
parties yeah you have to get like a plus
one you know because they're already
invited
i mean i know i'm actually trying to
think about imagining that with my
sister we are close but sometimes we
need our space so does she just live in
new york yeah she does how if you see
your sister um like a couple times a
week okay yeah it's the best right so i
mean she's she's my everything she's
great on the show she's oh yeah i know
does she like filming
well she
i mean it's funny because she just she's
so herself i mean she's literally
doesn't change at all like in front of
all the cameras um i think that i don't
i don't know if she loves it
do you when you wrote your book i'm sure
you talked a lot about your family and
did you give them like a copy of the
magic i gave them a yeah we discussed
beforehand and did they get a veto
um there was a couple things my mom had
me change oh my god speaking of your mom
you went viral on tick tock recently and
i was cracking up because i honestly
didn't know if you were serious or not
yeah either you made this tick tock
saying oh i just flew my whole family
out i paid for this amazing vacation
they think we're here to have fun but
i'm actually going to stage an
intervention on our generational trauma
and like all the problems in our family
and you went so viral it was so funny
what did you end up doing so i was
joking but at the same time my mom's a
therapist and anytime our whole family's
together
it's therapeutic i mean we talk about
our
functionality and our feelings and our
issues and like
we can't help it we're all
very
like over the top whatever eccentric i
guess i don't know so i made that it's a
it was a joke i didn't just bring them
there for that obviously like i it was
actually supposed to be kind of a
healing trip for
my mom losing my grandmother and
yeah my mother said something like i
don't know how many more christmases i
have left and i was like oh god
and i got it so i normally don't even
spend christmas with my family i always
go to jamaica alone with kiki so this
was like a big special trip
to be together and um it was a joke yeah
but then i ended up kind of talking to
them and then putting that up well tick
tock was like lit aflame they were like
what was the overwhelming consensus from
the comments i think some it was like 50
50 like some people were like you're the
biggest narcissist for doing that
meanwhile i actually like went out of my
way to do something nice for my family
and i was joking but then other people
were like good but you're never probably
going to get what you need from them you
know
um
and then i ended up talking to them
about something
yeah and i didn't get what i needed it
was not productive
you know what it was fine that it it was
good it was productive but
that kind of work you have to do on your
own anyway
so
what was it like growing up with a mom
as a therapist
it was um
uh
i mean i like started doing drugs at age
14 oh right i forgot about that so it
was that's not like i don't yeah i don't
i wouldn't blame it i'm not blaming on
her being a therapist or anything like
that but for whatever reason i
was like really rebellious and really
i had a huge appetite for
self-destruction you know what's so
crazy because on the show last week we
had josh peck who was obviously like a
child actor and now he's like a
successful influencer and he went
through four years of crazy addiction um
and it's just so crazy when you meet
someone like our only impression of you
is like you on the other side of your
addiction yeah but you saw me drinking
on season oh that's true but like it was
like fun you were amongst like so many
alcoholics like you were just one of the
girls you know it wasn't like well when
you're surrounded by other people who
are getting blackouts or even crazy
right so it's just so weird because for
me like you're so like just calm and you
have this like very um serene aura about
you so i honestly can't picture it it
was the same with josh that's all the
meds i can't picture you in that
delinquent space you described i was i
was
if my daughter did 10
of what i was doing i would be in a
grave right
i don't know how my parents did it and
how old is your daughter now 14. oh damn
yeah and she's a great she's great yeah
she's great what so when you say an
addict were you doing drugs
yeah what kind of drugs um crystal meth
crystal acid ecstasy because i was a
raver i was a club right
like
so that's what you were doing at the
clubs like it was normal that is so
crazy crystal meth special k
like ketamine yeah yeah yeah yeah like k
holes yeah no when you go out new york
like everyone's doing drugs but i don't
think i've ever seen anyone do crystal
meth yeah well now it's very popular in
the gay community oh is it very very
very but back in the day it was like
like have people do like coke like like
it's nothing yeah kind of even though
they should really be careful because
is crazy people left and right but back
then it was just a club drug because you
know you'd have to dance for two hours
10 a.m how else are you gonna do that
how does one do crystal meth you do it i
mean uh are you injective no i i didn't
but you can yeah like you would just
sniff it some people smoke it i didn't
do that interesting yeah wow that's so
crazy and so how you're at the club i
mean so i guess you could go into the
bathroom and shoot but you're bringing
your needles is like very
like yeah so how long have you been off
drugs oh i've been like off drugs for a
long time god and you are now totally
sober i'm totally sober i don't even
smoke weed
which i actually in my book at that time
was like i'm still i smoke weed but i'm
completely
sober now and in your mind like what
what is different i mean i'm sure it's a
lot of but like what's different about
day-to-day life as a totally sober
person
i mean i
it's i i mean like look i converted to
judaism right like i'm on a different
crazy thing it's like yeah you know mine
crazy now is much different than what it
used to be but the issue is i do have to
like check myself because somehow i'm
still
like maybe have this
need for excitement and chaos like i
talk about right but i have to like fill
it up with other things right you know
you have a lot of hobbies
uh i do have a lot of hobbies and there
and it's kind of crazy how many
different things i've taken up since i
got sober years ago like ice skating i
became like an adult ice skater not like
i'm not like professional i could do
like a little waltz jump right in
no i was going and taking lessons where
at chelsea pierce i'm shook
yeah and i would always see um jonathan
van ness there
because he would be taking the lessons
in the morning at the same time and i
was like oh [ __ ] um but it's amazing
like really you know listen drugs are
fun if you're not an addict and an
alcoholic you know and if you can do
them recreationally i totally believe
like listen like taking acid i've was
like i had spiritual experiences like
i'm i'm not against it you know
um for people if it works for them but
but have but being an addict is like
[ __ ] dark and it's like a lifelong
it's a it never goes away right i can't
like just start i can't have a glass of
wine really yeah no never did you find
being um amongst the women
at the beginning of your journey on real
houses in new york to be really testing
your so it was interesting because i had
relapsed a few months before i got
casted or knew i was going to be on the
show and then i was like oh my god i'm
going to be on a reality show and i'm
drinking again i know that that's a
disaster waiting to happen but i just
couldn't stop right i wasn't ready but
i'm i ha i can't lie i'm happy that the
year i did drink i was drinking with
like dorinda and sonia no like that's
quite
awesome
when we see the women like in some of
the states we've seen them in like late
at night how many drinks are we having
oh my god like 20. yeah like it's just
all night they're not they're all dead
they're tanks it's they're they're i've
never seen anything like it like i
remember one night like me and luanne
went out and after filming we were out
till like four in the morning and we had
like we had to [ __ ] show up at 9am i
took her she took me to some place on
the every side i took her to one oak
like oh it was at luann out
it was it was awesome
and then like the next morning we had to
show up at like 9 00 a.m for us you know
to film and it was when ramona i said
[ __ ] i elevate that [ __ ] it was that i
think it was it was that i had to show
up that day i was so hungover i show up
and like oh i'm sorry no it was after
halloween halloween oh luanne shows up
and is like bright as a daisy like
nothing like no issues and i'm like like
no makeup like one of my producers is
like what the [ __ ] like you look like
[ __ ] you know and i'm like how do they
do this no kids next level i don't know
how they do it that's and especially at
their age because really the older you
get the worse your hangovers get you
would think so you would think but no
there are machines no machines ramona is
the best though because she never even
gets
she gets sloppy no she gets drunk but
like she doesn't
it's different like she doesn't like get
like in trouble yeah that's true
she i mean she should
what
yes she is known honestly i wouldn't be
surprised if i mean that's pretty bad i
wouldn't be surprised if one of the
people who writes in on unburdening
yourselves is ramona because people are
always talking about getting drunk and
[ __ ] their pants apparently it's
like it's like a big thing
thank god that never happened to me i
mean it came close i just recovered from
the stomach flu so i can no longer say
that that hasn't happened to me but um
it wasn't out of my control it was no
what happened to me with stomach flu
it's not drunk yeah there is a stomach
flu going around i don't know if you
know that and i just want to encourage
you because i didn't know that it was
going around i just want to encourage
you to like be really safe okay like
it's no [ __ ] joke i know no i know i
saw you like laid up in bed but
by the way i have an iv vitamin guy for
you uh-huh that is oh yeah you were
telling me yes he's the best okay let me
use like my little secret like
there's really nothing an iv can't fix
yeah i love it but i said i was getting
them so much when i had covet and i
think it like made me crazy for like
when did you have cove what uh
i had the um i think i got it at bill
bouquet so i had the upper east side
bill bouquet straight oh so it was like
really snobby yeah it's like that really
like rich strain
[Laughter]
oh man that's so funny um okay well
we're gonna get into more news and the
rest of the show is brought to you by
bowling branch the best sheets on the
planet their signature sheets come in
nine versatile colors all sizes from
twin up to california king and you'll
immediately feel the difference in their
iconic signature sheets that's what i
have on my bed and then literally
everything in my house is from bowling
brand check my throw blankets um they
fit the deepest mattresses and are
labeled with top and bottom tags so
making your bed is a journey and it's
not that hard best of all bowling branch
gives you a 30 night risk free trial
with free shipping and returns they use
100 best organic cotton
and they have a superior softness and a
better night's sleep their sheets aren't
just buttery they're breathable and impo
and possibly soft to start they get
softer with every wash so get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code toast at bowlingbranch.com
that's bowlin branch spelled
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code toast how
often do you change your sheet slim mix
sweetie once a week give me two i mean
it's when my cleaning lady comes into me
as well yeah um and it's just like
there's or else i wouldn't do it for
like a month no no before i had i period
all over it and then that's when i
change it what is your policy on eating
in bed
um
some people are like really against it
oh i would [ __ ] do it in a heartbeat
i i just don't do it like i haven't been
doing it but like i'm totally with that
yeah me too i think there's literally
nothing better than posting up in bed
eating yeah but if i have a dog and i
know you have pets i don't have a tv in
my bedroom what i know so set an
intentional like thing yeah i think just
like one seat my daughter has one in her
room that she uses for video games but
like i feel like two is like enough like
i can't like have one in my room that's
so interesting watching it too much you
know i've been all about like i'm really
trying to do like sleep hygiene lately
what's up
it's like really
uh like turning your lights down um
after sunset like making sure everything
is like you know so your circadian clock
can like be like a caveman's
interesting is it working i think so
i've been sleeping well like not being
on your phone you know it's all about
that blue light yes that actually is a
real thing it's a real thing i know
trying to read before bed maybe instead
of watching tv i haven't been great at
it the last couple nights what's the
last book you read
um the anatomy of anxiety
oh dark it's great yeah no it's so good
i'm not i'm not into like like i just
like to read like fictional books about
it i'm reading now and now i'm reading a
fictional book called lucky
cute yeah um i love you a kindle are you
a hardcover girl hardcover yeah no it's
just like who is a space we live in new
york you know yeah i don't know space
for books that's true oh i love i know i
have so many books i know and it's like
what do you do with that i know they're
right now on my tv media
that's like where they are like they're
all there literally
um okay let's keep going with the
stories because uh kim kardashian's on
good morning america this morning and
robin roberts is asking the tough
questions she's asking her to clarify
her uh get your [ __ ] ass up and work
comments um
obviously that little sound bite went so
viral on tik-tok and all other platforms
with tick-tock as well and people were
like really hella pissed at him being
like you're so privileged what are you
telling us to work like you're a
billionaire you grew up with a maid um
and then robin roberts asked her about
it and i feel like it's crazy like
i can't recall a time in recent memory
where kim is like addressing a
controversy but what she said was well
that statement that i said was without
questions and the conversation around it
it became a sound bite really with no
context and that sound bite came off the
notion and the question right before
which was after 20 years of being in the
business you're famous for being famous
and my whole tone and attitude changed
with that previous question
that went into that question about what
advice i would give to women so
i guess she's basically saying she still
said no one wants to work right she said
it wasn't a blanket statement towards
women or to feel like i don't respect
the hard work or think that they don't
work hard i know that they do it was
taken out of context but i'm really
sorry that it was received that way
i mean maybe she just said something and
like people shouldn't take it as gospel
no i know what i mean it's like that's
serious it's not that serious yeah it's
just not that serious but that's like
maybe kim isn't perfect and she has some
like problematic [ __ ] or whatever
like right no one like we're human like
it's not that deep it's not that deep i
agree it's not completely the other
thing is like
yes okay they grew up you know with a
maid and in beverly hills and blah blah
they still like i mean i know a lot of
people grow up like that yeah they're
not able to turn
right exactly they like you know so
i i'm not even i'm not a fan or a hater
of hers i'm pretty like neutral with her
i've never watched one of the i've never
even seen one of those
i know i haven't that's insane yeah but
you're also a julia fox girly right
you're friends with julia yeah so what
does that mean for you oh that's right
right um even though i don't julia and
kim are cool yeah i don't think there
was any static between them when that
whole thing was going down and like
you're like i know this girl and she's
now like becoming this major deal like
what was going through your mind i was
like if anyone can handle this julia ken
really is like she's good for it like
i'm just like if anyone can handle this
and turn it into something good for her
right and not have it be like she she
just she killed i mean she did a great
job yeah like she went from like dating
him only for like three weeks and then
by kanye and now she's like at you know
the person
oscar [ __ ] donatella yeah no you know
what i mean that's pretty epic
like there's no no one else is doing
that did you get a birkin
i didn't get a bergen [ __ ] i wasn't
invited i know
yeah that's a problem that's a bummer
that's a bummer
that was just like such a crazy time in
pop culture history like it was pretty
cool it was crazy and were you
communicating with her while i was going
on no but i was just watching and how do
you know her
um and i'm saying this because me and
her spoke about it on her podcast
i'm was her sponsor in aaa years ago
and we just stayed friends she was in
some of my married to the mob campaign
oh cool yeah actually jerry saltz just
posted a photo um from it and she i
don't even know if he knows that it's
her in the in the t-shirt sounds so
interesting yeah yeah yeah you're so
like new york downtown stuff i guess
where'd you grow up in chelsea on 24th
and 8th but then i moved to connecticut
when i was 14. got it and then i moved
back when i was 18. got it got it got it
i mean that's so interesting the julia
fox of it all right so
yeah kim um
like honestly kim could do no wrong like
i just love you so much
and
while i like people are taking yes i
think i do believe he was taken out of
context and people are just like so
pressed over it but at the end of the
day like the overall message was just
like if you want to be successful you
have to work hard and that's true that
is true um i often wonder though if kim
is
she's either like buddha or like a total
sociopath
she's extremely calm it's wild yeah like
how
she said i always reference this moment
on like the last episode of the old
e-show when like the kanye stuff was
like starting
she said calmness is her superpower like
that's really how she gets through life
and i was like never been more jealous
of anyone in my life because i'm like
what is calm i've never been calm in my
life i'm calm when i'm sleeping and like
that's it
maybe she has a really strong faith or
something maybe they are i think they
are pretty religious yeah but it's like
scary with her it's like either very
sociopath she either like doesn't have
feelings or she literally is like buddha
like i don't know no that's a really
good call i also think like the kim that
we know like i don't think we know like
80 of kim's actual personality yeah
that's just what i think that's
interesting i could see that which
kardashian do you feel like most like do
you associate with um
you're giving kendall really yeah like
superman
i don't know if i really
you know you don't play that game at
your like family dinner yeah no i'm
trying to think i'm like i don't know
like
my like sister's so hot so like maybe
like chloe because i felt like the ugly
sister for a long time and i know she
said that she feels that way i'm not
calling her the ugly sister um but then
i also like you know courtney
just seems like she's doing her own
thing
and like doesn't care about being famous
that much so i'm kind of into that and
she feels like she's in like the season
of her life where she's extremely at
peace yeah content with her life and her
family and she's in love and there's
nothing better than that i'm definitely
not in love do you want to get married
again
i was never married uh what yeah but we
were together right right i didn't know
that yeah
do you want to be in a partnership or a
relationship you know what i um i
haven't really wanted to so i haven't
been looking for that you're on the apps
i'm not on apps i'm not
doing anything i've only had sex once
this year wow and i think i jinxed
myself with my tagline from last season
which was i'm sex positive and bs
negative yeah and then it was like
anywhere
i was like okay i'm still sex positive i
just i'm not having it that is beyond
funny
um
well speaking of the rob of it all our
next story actually is not that big of a
deal but i did want to get your take on
just like co-parenting in general
because i feel like we see a lot of
people on tv co-parenting when i think
of like the healthy ones i think of you
um and kim and kanye were just spotted
they were at a saint soccer game oh good
there was like paparazzi pictures they
didn't appear to be like loving or
embracing one another but they were both
there that's a good thing yeah i imagine
like co-parenting is literally the
hardest thing in the world especially if
you [ __ ] hate your partner yeah like
luckily i don't hate rob you know and i
don't think like it doesn't seem like
kim hates connie i think she kind of
probably feels for him a bit i feel like
she's definitely annoyed by him annoyed
maybe yeah
um but
i
you know if you're a good parent you put
your kid first right and that's what you
have to do you can't really like think
about your own ego you have to just do
it but as again i'm in a fortunate
situation yeah where he never did
anything horrible right or i probably
wouldn't be good at co-parenting were
you guys like from the start like once
you decided to not be together were you
always in like a good spot no no that
was a period it was like the first
couple years was like rough yeah yeah
and then we kind of it's been it's been
an evolution you know as we've both
gotten older and like more mature and
just like chilled out
it gets better yeah i feel like having a
good like positive healthy co-parenting
space is like a the hardest thing to do
and b it's like in my opinion the most
admirable because you have to be so
mature and that's just something i'm not
well
i'm mature in that way but maybe not in
other ways
totally well honestly i'm happy for kim
and kanye i feel like we beat this horse
dead like i'm just so
over talking about these two which is
crazy for me
i'm really done with like talking about
kanye he's really annoying me and like
all of his tweets i mean his instagrams
like it's so toxic and like i
i'm really not a principled person like
i'm just kind of toxic
but like i feel like talking about
family publicly on social media like
that is a lot and that's something i
hate and like
just i imagine how unsettling it is for
kim to like have this person be a loose
cannon who you were married to who knows
like all your deepest darkest secrets
seeing you at your worst terrifying
what's scarier than that that is
terrifying and so like but i'm like is
he saying like sometimes i'm like is he
trying to like are these calls for help
is he
is it true like was she really keeping
him away but then she said no stop she
was like you were literally here this
morning like stop yeah so if that's the
case then yeah he's completely
in the wrong well and he has been like
very open about his struggles with
mental health and it's clear yeah that's
why i have a soft spot i know so it's
clear for me like this whole thing is
him spiraling in that sense but also at
the at the end of the day it's like it's
still like he's still harassing him so
it's like where do we i don't know where
to fall this is the difference i think
uh you know
success and wealth has not been good for
his soul
and kim it's a different story yeah like
she's thriving in it and i don't think
that it's been great for him yeah and i
think especially since he became a
father it's been like more taxing for
him and i think for her she's entered
like a season of her life where she's so
much more secure with the fame and
everything yeah no that's actually a
really good point
well i just love to see you know
families coming together because of
course this is a family show you know
yeah absolutely um our fifth and final
story is some sad news sadly over the
weekend the foo fighters drummer taylor
hawkins had passed away and an autopsy
revealed he had 10 substances in his
system when he died so the colombian
authorities on saturday said that the
foo fighters drummer taylor hawkins had
10 substances when he was found dead in
his bogota um
in bogota on friday so the office of the
attorney general colombia tweeted the
update which is just like so bizarre
saying that a preliminary toxicology
test found substances including opioids
benzodiazepines trisilic antidepressants
and thc and psychoactive compound in
marijuana they didn't rule it as the
official cause of death and said that
the investigation is ongoing and results
will be released after they continue
i wonder if there was offense i know um
so sad so sad and a lot of celebrities
have like spoken out about this and
miley cyrus was actually performing over
the weekend and she broke down crying i
think she's saying a foo fighter song um
so sad so crazy
and
yeah new update 10 substances in the
system when he died
addiction is really
reeled up yeah it's very real
yeah it like with stories like this it's
just like impossible it's just so sad
especially like when someone's at the
height of their career like foo fighters
is
huge and he has like three kids i think
oh that's terrible it's horrible
horrible you you just hate to see it and
yeah i mean i'm sure
in your experience with drugs i'm sure
you've seen a lot of things like that i
had a lot of friends right now yeah so
sad sucks that's terrible um well we're
sending his family the best and we're
just to pivot a little bit slightly
happier which is unburdening ourselves
so let me tell you how this segment came
to be
um
i fell
yeah
i fell at a party
at a cool party mary kate ashley and
ashley were there yeah and i was wearing
these like big dino stomper shoes and
so the thing was is that um
i don't know
and it's kind of the unknown that keeps
me up at night yeah and so
it was like a friday or saturday night
and it's just the whole weekend it
plagued me and i asked my friend gabe
who was with me i'm like did you see and
he said no and like i knew he was lying
and then on monday i came here on the
show and i talked it through with jackie
and i really did feel better yeah um and
jackie let me know that's called
unburdening yourself oh unburdening and
then i thought you know why should i
keep this to myself let's open it up to
everyone to be able to unburden
themselves you share about people right
i'm really just like an empath
and i sense other people's trauma yeah
and so what i wanted to do was open the
floodgates for other people so every
week on monday we let three people
unburden themselves they tell us what
they did this weekend that's been
plaguing them and then they can
officially let it go love that we try
really hard not to judge them but again
some people do crazy things and it's not
always that easy
so we are going to unburden ourselves
brought to you by stamps.com time is
money don't waste either with repeated
trips to the office with stamps.com you
can skip the trip and focus on how to
take your small business to the next
level stamps.com lets you fit print
official postage right from your
computer it saves you money in the
process so you can spend less time at
the post office office and more time
making your customers happy so for more
than 20 years stamps.com has been an
indispensable asset for over 1 million
businesses they give you access to all
the post office and ups shipping
services you need right from your
computer and you get discounts you can't
find anywhere else like 40 off usps
rates and 76
off ups rates so stop overpaying for
shipping with stamps.com sign up with
the promo code toast for a special offer
that includes a four week trial free
postage and a digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code toast
okay do you do this every day the
morning toast yeah yes monday through
friday impressive thank you so much
honestly thank you so much for being
here like i just no this is you're like
a mogul i can't stress it enough how
grateful i am
ready yes oh sorry did i interrupt you
no never please if you have something to
say leah this is an open space okay
anything else
no okay you let me know
this past monday i had a huge exam
coming up it wasn't a big deal because
it was my best subject and i studied a
ton for it my roommates and i walk into
the exam and we sit down in the lecture
hall along with 230 other kids we get
the test and begin the first few answers
are going well i knew the material and i
felt really good about my knowledge i
start to feel my stomach churn
and i make some noises oh god noises
that are so loud around me everyone can
hear i run out of the room of 230 kids
and i sprint to the restroom where i
basically had an accident in my pants i
had to dispose of my underwear in the
school bathroom
i pull myself together and go find the
professor and i'm shaking explaining to
him what happened and i'm crying because
i think i stink
i tried to continue the rest of the exam
feeling so embarrassed and disgusted and
for the entire
rest of the exam i'm sweating and
feeling like it's happening again i had
no idea what i put on the exam and i
never really finished it i left and i
told my roommates a bit of what happened
they had no idea what was happening
during the exam i'm scared to go back to
class to check my exam turns out i had
food poisoning and i was in the bathroom
for the next two days of course it had
to hit me during my
exam oh my god
she should be able to take her exam
again that's completely i mean that's a
medical thing emergency yeah emergency i
agree and i think when you spoke to the
professor like he should have been like
[ __ ] go home
and we'll take care of this later
especially if you smell like [ __ ] the
thing is like with college professors
like they act sometimes like the exams
are life or death like you could be
bleeding out it's like well you have to
finish your exam it's like they're so
serious like you can't miss a moment
like your life is gonna end right in
your pants you should be able to go home
you should be able to go home and sit on
a toilet yeah and that's like the human
thing to let someone it's a basic human
right basic human right is to [ __ ] in a
toilet 100 yep i'm so sorry that
happened to you i hope you can unburden
yourself and know it was out of your
control trust me i'm recovering from the
stomach flu like you guys know i went
into extreme detail about what happened
to me like
sometimes our bodies betray us and this
is one of those moments and i'm so sorry
that happened to you yeah it happened to
me too but not in public but yeah in the
beginning no we had a stomach issue i
don't know it was bad there's literally
nothing more embarrassing because it's
so out of your control there's then you
have to like clean it no it's horrible
and then like you have to walk around
like without underwear on because you
crapped your pants like a toddler like
it's horrible yeah i'm so sorry that
happened to you i hope you can let this
go and you know what i really would talk
to your professor about getting a new
test because that ain't right absolutely
how can you focus on algebra when like
you're literally crabbing your pants at
least it wasn't on tv
exactly have you ever crapped your pants
on tv no just just ramona hell no
that was horrifying like the skid marks
on the floor
um
all right next up thank you for sharing
by the way this is an open safe space
good morning jackie good morning claudia
and jackie slash to be named co-host
leah thank you for being here
um my husband thinks it's really funny
to annoy the [ __ ] out of me it's like
his love language
it might turn me into a murderer someday
so after a shower on days that he's
being extra annoying or we're fighting i
take his towel
to dry my butt crack it's my way of
getting back at him
without him ever knowing is that
unsanitary probably but does it bring me
instant relief when i'm very pissed
absolutely love you
honestly i'd love that for you but i do
feel like there's a problem in your
marriage like maybe you guys should talk
about yeah because that's a big problem
well that doesn't enjoy like
him drying off with butt cracks how old
yeah i know like and if it's a
consistent thing you're doing like i
don't want to be in nice hair but like i
do feel like there might be a problem in
your marriage you sound like you hate
him yeah and he sounds like he hates you
too like being annoying get a divorce
yeah being annoying is not a love
language it's not a personality trait
it's just you're [ __ ] annoying and no
one wants to be around you yeah yeah i
love this for you i do um but i would
maybe explore
therapy couples therapy yep definitely
because it sounds like you two are
but probably don't ever admit that you
did that i know it's so beyond
embarrassing like and it makes you look
[ __ ] crazy nuts i agree do not ever
tell anyone you did that but just know
like next time you're wiping your ass
with this table like think like is this
what marriage is no it's not like it's
supposed to be fun and better so yeah i
would
i know that might not be the answer you
were looking for here but there's
definitely sounds like there's a problem
in your marriage
right here's our third and final one and
it's beyond
hey girly girls this weekend i was out
having a good time with my girlfriend
and we ended up closing down the bars we
were drunkenly wandering around the
streets waiting to call an uber to go
home because the prices were so high and
we were just hoping to wait it out and
that they would eventually get lower
because it was 2 am everything was was
closed and my bladder was about to
explode i was asking all these strangers
on the street who would listen where can
i go pee and one man finally said you
can use my hotel room
and i did
i'm not proud and i literally don't
trust any man ever but i really could
not hold it in any longer so i decided
to take the risk of getting murdered and
go on in luckily he was very normal and
after we peed he asked if we wanted a
drink we said no thank you anyways i
just felt the need to unburden myself
because anytime i think about this i
want to die i can't believe i trusted my
drunken self to a strange man off the
street
next time just pop a squat between two
cars a hundred percent you don't need to
go to anyone's hotel room or a
restaurant or anything just pee on the
streets totally fine i don't want to
make you feel worse because like you do
feel bad but like i just want to
reiterate how dumb this was
um like beyond stupid and trust me i've
been there like i sometimes think about
some of the things i did like when i've
had like a couple drinks and i'm
mortified and like beyond
shook like how am i still alive so i
know the feeling and i'm not trying to
make you look bad same we just want you
to like not get murdered yeah and like
what's i i think like you know maybe
getting a ticket for like public
urination is better than getting
murdered in a man's hotel room like i
just think it's important that we weigh
our options absolutely
so again not trying to make you feel bad
but don't ever [ __ ] do that again
that is so dumb and moronic um well i
hope everyone feels better i feel better
anything you want to unburden um
well you're sober now so you probably
don't have anything there's not
something you know there's not that much
that's like i'm so jealous of that
no i'm kidding there's so much but i
have professionals yeah right and you
probably put it all in your i have a
team you put it all in your book it's
all in my book that is one big unburden
100 chaos siri anything you want us to
know about the book before we wrap um
you it
releases on april 5th you can go to my
instagram at liamob and order it i
should have brought it and like promoted
i know i was thinking that i was like i
should have put it next to yours mine's
no everything so your cover is dope by
the way thank you so much every now and
then i do
sadly have to put my book down for our
guests book but you didn't bring one so
i hope you promote mine that's okay well
um it comes out april 5th available
everywhere available everywhere you can
order it now
and i hope you love it i'm excited to
read it i'm a big reader and you need to
read it of course and i love a good
memoir and i love i'm sure there's some
good bravo juicy tidbits in there as
well there's great there's everything i
can't wait so congrats on the book
congrats on conversion if you have any
questions you want to come over for
shabbat like thank you
no let's like definitely chat about that
um okay thank you so much for being here
everyone follow leah on instagram at
liam her book comes out april 5th it's
called chaos theory thank you for being
here we genuinely appreciate it
we're back tomorrow with girl boss town
and then jackie joins us remotely on
wednesday to check in with how she's
doing so thank you so much for listening
to the morning shows millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio box all the
places where you listen to podcasts find
us the morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow bye
you